dans cet immeuble éventré par
l'artillerie russes au centre de kharkiv
un message d'espoir
anthony anastasia sont ensemble depuis
deux ans
ils ont décidé de se marier au milieu
des ruines et sous les caméras
afin de sensibiliser le monde pour
martyrs de leur ville
les amoureux se diront oui dans le m 2
karkhiv converti un immense centre de
réfugiés
des milliers d'habitants citer 1 depuis
40 jours pour échapper aux bombes
entre la peur la faim et les maladies un
peu de joie et bienvenus
[Applaudissements]
invité d'honneur le maire de kharkiv en
personne qui se bat mité jour de faire
face à la crise humanitaire
[Applaudissements]
nous avions rencontré anton et anastasia
à la veille du mariage
de son peiné vol dans un centre de
distribution de nourriture et de
matériel médical
je suivrai pas la chasse des seconds
pourquoi elle n'a
heureusement je ne la voient s'achever
une bouteille d'eau
et d'autres d'ukrainiens l'économie
participe sans réplique à l'effort de
guerre depuis les arrières
skype n'a stoppé que les uns et
les autres au niveau d'abobo le
président de la fsf beaucoup retenu
président ya
bientôt six semaines que les russes
pilonnent en ville sans pitié
à tout moment à kharkiv n'importe où la
mort peut tomber du ciel
ici une pluie de missiles grad vient
juste de s'abattre ce magasin de jouets
n'a pas été épargné
pour 300 civils au moins ont péri à
kharkiv sous les bombes depuis le début
de l'invasion russe
cet homme est en vie par miracle
[Musique]
pas de voyage de noces pour les jeunes
mariés
ils redoutent déjà d'efforts au centre
de bénévoles
conscient que la bataille ne fait que
commencer
et qu'elle sera terrible
[Musique]